deux frères ont un tour du monde à vélo
c'est l'aventuré
dennebroeucq que vous suivez sans doute
sur tv 78 au gré des épisodes nous avons
également proposé un reportage récemment
sur leur confinement au pérou laventure
bayrou qui a été mis en tout cas en
pause pour le moment en raison des
mesures sanitaires ils sont revenus en
france les deux frères taurin qui sont
avec nous cabinet et guillaume bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez donc dû revenir en
france
c'était jeudi dernier vous êtes revenu
jeudi dernier le 23 avril vous étiez en
confinement au pérou déjà le fait de
rentrer cette décision pourquoi l'avoir
prise et est ce que c'était une décision
difficile à prendre
oui très difficile à prendre parce qu'on
a initialement début du confinement au
pérou on voulait rester au pérou on
pensait attendre quelques semaines
mais au fil des semaines on a vu la
situation s'aggrave et puis entendre
différents présidents dans le monde dire
que cette situation allait durer très
longtemps
deuxièmement le pérou a fermé ses
frontières le 22 avril
donc nous avant cette période on s'est
dit mais est-ce que c'est raisonnable de
rester aussi longtemps au pérou et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire pendant tout ce
temps si on doit rester très longtemps
donc en mettant d'un côté les pourrait
d'un côté les contres s'est dit que le
plus raisonnable pour pour nous pour
notre santé c'était de rentrer en france
ouai et kevin guillaume ledit l'ailé
frontière du pérou était fermée du coup
comment ça ça organiser le rapatriement
comment vous avez pu revenir en france
alors en fait c'est un peu particulier
c'est les frontières de l'espace aérien
qui était fermée à partir du 22 avril
il faut savoir que les frontières ont
été fermées mi mars
quant au début du confinement au pérou
frontières terrestres et les frontières
aériennes mais on va dire plus
touristique donc du coup c on a eu en
fait pas recette des vols à destination
de paris mais avec assez particulier on
était plus à l'aéroport
international de lima on était à
l'aéroport militaire donc on était
carrément déposé sur le tarmac et donc
c'est les militaires qui nous ont pris
en charge les militaires français les
militaires péruviens et la gendarmerie
aussi français ça nous a fait assez
c'est assez intriguant de les voir sur
le territoire péruvien étrangers pour le
coup après ça s'est très très bien passé
une organisation assez assez incroyable
même de la part de l'ambassade de france
au pérou c'est hallucinant tout ce qui a
été mis en oeuvre pour on va dire on dit
rapatriement mais en soi c'est pas le
terme exact apparemment donc on a saisi
cette dernière opportunité de rentrer
dans des conditions vraiment vraiment
spectaculaire à paris pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu le reportage sur votre
confinement pérou ça ressemble à quoi
d'être confiné au pérou il ya plusieurs
règles qui ont été mis en place assez
rapidement par le pérou la première
c'était un couvre-feu
donc à partir alors selon les régions
bien sûr mais en gros à partir de 18
heures on pouvait plus sortir jusqu'à 5
heures du matin le lendemain
pendant un moment il ya eu des sorties
que par genre donc certains jours était
réservé aux hommes et d'autres jours
pour pour les femmes
ensuite il ya eu des débats les magasins
ont beaucoup de magasins qui était fermé
mais ça c'était pareil en france
c'était beaucoup de petites règles qui
se mettait en place assez rapidement au
pérou le port du masque qui était
obligatoire il conseillait aussi de
porter des gants
donc c'était difficile à trouver mais
c'est vrai que deux semaines de
confinement mais beaucoup qui avaient
des masques
alors papa les bombes à ce que c'était
de la débrouille tout ça mais la
population sait s'adapter assez
rapidement confinement pérou et
maintenant c'est le confinement france
tv nous et voilà du coup maintenant
c'est quand il ment en france donc l'un
guillaume et dans les yvelines tout
proche de vous l'autre donc moi je suis
je te planquer leur bretagne dépaysement
total pour le courant ne passait de lima
villes très peuplées avec pas mal de à
l'époque des pollutions à une bonne
campagne française ça fait quand même
bien plaisir de revoir tout ça même si
le décalage est pour le moment assez
fort il n'ya pas que le décalage horaire
il ya plein de choses qui reviennent ça
c'est assez particulier mais ont donc là
on se met comme en 14 heures auparavant
c'est ce qu'il faut dire le temps que on
voit on constate bien quand même on
était dans un avion 300 personnes en
contact 12 heures dans l'avion donc on
essaie d'enlever mes symptômes dus du
coup renault virus y en avait et puis on
va ressortir tranquillement on l'espère
tous mes dates du monde bien
effectivement qui sera le début du
déconfinement et tout ça alors cette
aventure elle a duré presque deux ans
vous êtes passé par l'europe l'afrique
l'amérique du sud pour pour terminer je
parlais tout à l'heure de pause vous
nous confirmez bien que c'est une pause
l'idée c'est aussi de repartir dès que
les conditions seront remplies
tout à fait on les l'idée initiale c'est
de faire un tour du monde à vélo
donc il est important pour nous d'aller
au bout donc on va attendre le temps
nécessaire et repartir dès que possible
je sais que c'est dur important a résumé
en quelques secondes mais qu'est ce que
vous en retenez en tout cas de ses deux
premières années quasiment une tour du
monde à vélo de petit tour du monde à
vélo du coup petit je ne sais pas quand
même il ya quand même le continent
effectivement mais en tout cas elle
voilà ce début de tour du monde qu'est
ce que vous obtenez je pense que 1 me
concernant ces îles il ya beaucoup fin
il ya beaucoup d'éléments à retenir
il ya d'énormes rencontre qu'on a faits
qui nous ont ils nous ont vraiment
remarqué pendant le voyage il ya aussi
l'aspect un peu plus négatifs qui est
puisqu'il touchait à la pollution et aux
déchets qu'on retrouve dans la nature et
ça c'est un constat qu'on a tous
remarqué il ya la pollution partout et
qu'il est très très très important et
urgent de faire attention à notre petite
planète et c'est une aventure
extraordinaire
et c'est sûr qu'on en a aujourd'hui déjà
on n'en revient pas comme comme on était
parti à l'origine beaucoup de
changements et beaucoup de changements
dans le voyage bon ben c'est à vivre
pour pour se rendre compte pour que les
gens puissent se rendre compte que c'est
c'est une autre vie et c'est très
enrichissant
je vois qu'ils essaient guillaume
peut-être des choses a ajouté vous vous
êtes totalement d'accord avec kevin oris
tout ce qui l'intéressé c'est exact on
pense qu'on est parti on pensait pas que
ça allait être aussi fort aussi prenants
il ya toutes les toutes les cultures
qu'on a qu'on a aussi rencontré ses
différents centres
on se doit par exemple le nord de
l'afrique et puis l'amérique du sud qui
est totalement différente et qui nous
ont enrichi du coup on a hâte
on a deux boucles et tout ça et bien on
vous souhaite de repartir très vite
merci
kevin et guillaume tora d'avoir été avec
nous merci beaucoup merci avec plaisir
et on pourra retrouver prochainement
quelques nouveaux épisodes des aventures
des gros des derniers épisodes tournés
avant à cette période de confinement